hier france 2 présenté à la presse le
prochain épisode de rendez vous en terre
inconnue
c'était l'occasion pour franck
gastambide ou brique et frédéric lopez
qu'il avait abandonnée à l'aéroport car
il ne présente plus l'émission c'est
raphaël de casablanca qui a pris sa
place visiblement franck non j'ai encore
à frédéric lopez regarde alors que
franck gastambide avait accepté de
participer à l'émission rendez vous en
terre inconnue le comédien s'est fait
lâcher au dernier moment par frédéric
lopez
en effet l'animateur a profité de cette
émission pour annoncer son départ ait
laissé franck s'envoler avec raphaël de
casablanca le nouvel animateur du
programme une pirouette que le comédien
n'a pas beaucoup apprécié comme il l'a
expliqué dans on n'est pas couché
l'abandon lâche pour ceux qui ne
seraient pas frédéric lopez a décidé de
ne plus animer lui même c'est évidemment
au détail près qu'il n'était évidemment
pas au courant de ça visiblement il
semble y avoir un froid entre les deux
hommes puisque à la conférence de presse
de l'émission ils se sont évités
frédéric lopez était la figure de proue
de rendez vous en terre inconnue des
émissions il en a animé et chic
des rumeurs s'étaient cattin alors
franck gastambide alesi donner votre
réponse que je me posais la question et
pendant ce temps là je m'appelais franck
gastambide pour voir s'il est vraiment
pas question je vais vous donner la
question s'il vous plaît c'est
bouleversant
avant de quitter l'aventuré combien de
numéro de rendez vous en terre inconnue
frédéric lopez a t'il animée entre 2014
et 2018 j'appellerai en gastambide comme
ça on va savoir va savoir si c'est vrai
ou pas se taper 1 alors que les vos
réponses les chéris un biel a animé ce
rendez vous à quelques inconnus vous
affichez les réponses
carole rousseau qui à fond dans le jeu
carole sachez qu'il ya des gagnants il
ya des perdants
deux appels point gastambide on va voir
l'écart sachiez que frédéric lopez
il va nous rappeler je pense pour
l'instant il est sur messagerie vous
connaissent un petit peu le principe il
en a animé 26 c'est donc géraldine
maillet qui tape loin avec 59
il anime et 26 en terrain connu voilà et
on va savoir si cette histoire et silva
long entre gaston qui n'est pas fait
c'est vrai que frédéric lopez il est
vrai ça s'était passé au quoi pas de ne
pas dire à son invité qu'on va pas aimé
l'imiter mais ça vous prépare n'a pas du
tout au second on accepte une émission
parce que c'est une marque qui allie un
référent animateurs ont en tout cas si
on n'est pas là on discute moi je ne
serais pas là si ça c'est pas du tout un
mois elles étaient parfois je suis pas
là je le dis pas ou alors vous êtes à
kaka sont pas ce qu'ils racontent
allez-y vous
[Applaudissements]
anzhi pense moi j'ai été surprise en
discutant avec lui hier ne le serait
pire avec franck de le sentir
effectivement blessé
je m'y attendais pas du tout je crois
que c'était une boutade est en fait pas
du tout il est resté un peu marqué par
le fait de n'avoir pas les normes bâle
qu'il était en panique si elle n'est pas
partir tout seul avec qui connaissait
pas l'autre ça la salle l'a vraiment
fait qu'elle savait qu'une femme
expérience côté frédéric lopez ou
quelqu'un d'autre ce qui est dit franck
aussi un ça va au delà de ça je pense
que s'il avait su que c'était pas
frédéric ne serais pas parti ne serait
pas l'idéal est d'en haut le duo
frédéric lopez lui à l'écran bien qu'ils
s'en moquent complètement de la cause en
fait impliqué que j'ai jamais vu ces
films buts au rendez-vous et intérêts à
mes meilleurs potes mais d'accord mais
quand même dire qu'il n'y pas que parce
que c'est frédéric lopez les a surpris
voilà mais il va être surpris mais on a
l'impression que c'est un drame et un
incident en guinée sommation serait
préparé différemment c'est tout voilà
c'est ça les métros il en fait trop il
est vrai que vous appelez il s'en sortir
avec une sorte d'humour un peu de
légèreté je pense que ça aurait été mais
le jury ne votent pas mais c'est bon
c'est bon alors passer à la quatrième
qui est parce que nous on choisit ce
moment mais il en aime une l'humour
après alors merci question on va
maintenant vous donner une information à
propos de cette fâcheuse histoire avec
le fc nantes et emiliano sala regarder à
c'est franck gastambide un super franck
comment ça va mon frère on merci ouais
ça va après mon bac elle me tombent
aussi je fais des emprunts non fait tout
et si tu sais que je travaille un petit
peu entre faut bien gagner sa croûte mon
vieux tout le monde va bien alors là il
ya géraldine maillet qui a défoncé
ce programme durant les jeux benjamin
castaldi qui t'as des fondus isabelle
morini-bosc tête à vue hier et pata des
vendus et guay voilà alors c'est vrai
cette histoire et frédéric lopez ou pas
par était énervé après federico pas
lâchement je te laisse surfer moi ça je
voulais déjà fait moi ça non mais et
parce que géraldine maillet disais c'est
tout disait alors ils s'en fichent de la
cause puisque il faut aparté que pour
frédéric lopez c'est pas du tout ça
je la connais pas vraiment très vite
parti je sais pas où tu voir cette
émission
ouais je sais pas où je vais mon seul
référent ses frais directs ça me rassure
si c'est pas lui
je sais pas si j'aurais été mais oui sur
le congé passer un moment émotionnel
très très difficile d'aller lever alors
et et franck à la fin à la fin du
programme
est ce que tu leur voix frédéric lopez
ou pas du tout ah ouais donc ne devra
pas d'ici là bon bah écoute j'espère que
ça va s'arranger d'ici là parce que
sinon elle va être sympa l'ambiance dans
l'émission tu sais ce que je vais faire
en parallèle mois pour qui et de bonne
ambiance sur ces 8 sur france 2 j'ai
invité bernard de la villardière
je t'embrasse mon frère capitale
[Applaudissements]